hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's november 10 2021 and if you
would like to chat live with other real
human beings
non-bots and no haters go to
reubenreport.locals.com you can chat
with the reuben report team and with
other viewers as we are doing the show
and your comments and questions might
make it to me to read live during the
show as always going forward we are now
streaming on rumble.com we're also on
youtube which announced today i don't
even know if you guys saw this youtube
announced today that the dislike button
they're going to leave the button but
they will no longer show you how many
people have clicked the dislike button
just another way that the machine
does not want you the individual
to know actually how much influence you
have the reason they're doing this of
course is because so many things are
coming out of the white house and
mainstream media that just get disliked
the comment sections are horrible so
they're shutting down comment sections
they don't want you to see the amount of
people that dislike things so they say
they're doing it to make the
conversation healthier but i assure you
nothing that youtube is doing will make
the conversation any healthier which is
why i'm very proud to be working with
rumble now and we are on the homepage of
rumble every day at 11am pacific which
it's about 1102 pacific right now you're
watching this right now do i have to
tell you that we got a great show for
you guys uh i do want to say that we are
not
100
not going to talk about kovid today you
know yesterday when we did the show it
ended up being a lot of covet nonsense
from vaccine mandates and you know the
administration ignoring
the uh
the court order saying that you can't
mandate and all of this stuff and i
spent probably about 20 or 25 minutes of
the show talking about covid and i
really felt kind of gross after like i
am so over
covered the virus now i get that we have
to deal with this other virus the mind
virus that is infecting everybody and
making people hate each other and
wanting people still to be in masks and
get the 18th jab and everything else so
i'm going to do one little thing related
to matthew mcconaughey in the first
story and covet and then that's really
it i'm going to try to figure out this
is my promise to you guys going forward
i'm going to try to figure out a way to
do less on covet in general because we
got to start moving on like we got to
start moving on a certain set of people
they ain't going to move on like it's
never going to be enough they'll get 87
jabs they'll wear a thousand different
masks on their face they'll lock
themselves in the basement and all that
and that's fine there's nothing we can
do for them and it's okay if that's how
half the country uh wants to live if
that's what the democrats want to run on
like it's i guess there's nothing i can
do but for those of you that watch this
show i want to help empower you to live
a better life right that's what i want
to do to myself it's what i want to do
with my team and it's what i want to do
with you guys and i don't think just
endlessly being like oh the government
is ridiculous this [ __ ] said this this
liar said this oh we caught them because
they said that last week and this this
week it's just
it's too much just like running in the
mud like i don't think we can just spin
our wheels like that and i want to
figure out new ways to to solve some of
the problems that's going to be sort of
my direction going forward i just felt
kind of gross i think i think it's
partly because i was in florida last
week where covert is just over
it's just over and people have moved on
so i don't want to focus too much on
just like
that we're surrounded by a lot of crazy
people i just want to focus on that so a
little something story number one
matthew mcconaughey and kovid then
number two uh this jimmy kimmel guy you
may know this guy he has this late night
show he's been in blackface um real
racist guy uh he thinks that people that
don't like kamala harris are racist and
uh yeah well well no it's just that
she's a horrible person uh and then
finally joking aside uh the kyle
rittenhouse trial
has been happening over the last couple
days a whole bunch of you asked why i
didn't cover it yesterday or the day
before as it was as it was happening and
there's a lot of testimony happening
actually right at this very moment
including kyle on the stand right now in
his own defense um and i didn't want to
cover it because there were so many
things happening at once i wanted it to
shake out a little bit more i feel like
today is the day that we can start
covering it a little more intensely so
we've got two videos from the trial
itself and a little bit of a recap of
the media of madness around it that
tucker carlson did last night in case
you didn't see it it's worth the watch
okay so that's the layout of the show
today and before i get to any of that i
want to talk to you guys about bonner
private wine you know any higher up and
the grapes wouldn't be able to survive
what does this mean for the wine a
flavor unlike any wine you've ever
tasted
blackberry leather smoke and a little
dark cherry this stuff packs a punch my
friends over at free thinker wine are
bringing these rare wines to americans
for the holidays the best part they've
cut out the middleman you won't deal
with any big industry markup while david
and i love to host these wines also make
great gifts if you're attending a dinner
party as a guest you know thanksgiving
is on the way and if you're curious
about the pairing malbecs go
particularly well with dark turkey meat
spices like sage and pepper and sauces
like creamy mushroom i'm getting hungry
already visit freethinkerwine.com and
you'll get top quality extreme altitude
wine for about half the price perfect
for your thanksgiving meal for the
family no need for a promo code just
visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com these malbecs are
delicious okay so real quick
we're gonna do some covid stuff but this
is really about someone standing up
against the madness that's the type of
covet stuff that i'll gladly cover not
just the oh the attorney
the surgeon general said this and the
scientists said this and fouchy's a
[ __ ] and the rest of that stuff this is
the kind of covet stuff that we actually
need to hear about so of course you all
know matthew mcconaughey all right all
right all right and interstellar and the
whole thing right we all know matthew
mcconaughey uh he's become pretty
outspoken at least as far as you know
being a hollywood celebrity um and he
lives in texas if i'm not mistaken
there's a rumor that maybe he's going to
run for governor of texas but uh you
know he's had conversations online with
jordan peterson like the guy gets it i
don't know that i agree with him on
everything i suspect i don't doesn't
matter he just seems like a decent guy
who is trying to use his brain to get
through this madness that we are being
subjected to every day and he is not
going to vaccinate his kids he would
like a little more info but listen to
him as many kids are rolling up their
sleeves for a shot before thanksgiving
with grandma another high-profile
celebrity is casting some doubt on
vaccines really for kids actor and
potential candidate for texas governor
matthew mcconaughey says well
he has taken the vaccine he's taking a
beat before getting his younger children
their shots
don't want to trust
in the science do i think that there's
any kind of scam or conspiracy theory
hell no i don't right now i'm not
vaccinated mine i'll tell you that
you're not um i'm not vaccinating mine i
want to get some i've been vaccinated my
wife has been vaccinated we have a high
risk person in our household my mother
who's 90 and she's immune compromised i
couldn't mandate having to vaccinate
the younger kids i still want to find
out i still want to find out more
information
and the truth is mcconaughey is not
alone here some parents say kids on
average tend not to get seriously ill if
they happen to get coveted so the
argument is let's just wait it out
oh so matthew mcconaughey would just
like more information he himself got
vaccinated because his mom's 90 and
lives in the house but he'd like a
little more information it was
interesting what the cnn
journalist said there at the end that
parents are starting to wonder it's like
well what you could have done there is
actually given some numbers about how
many deaths there's been for kids 5 to
11 years old you could have read the cdc
numbers that i repeat here endlessly on
the show every week point zero zero two
percent morbidity for kids five to
eleven and there's a lot of evidence
that it's significantly less than that
it's about 500 kids but many of them had
all sorts of other
conditions lots of kids get kovid they
get sort of mild sickness and they're
sick for a couple days and that's pretty
much it and then they get natural
antibodies and all that anyway what's
going to happen to matthew mcconaughey
now is that the machine is going to go
after him for sure he did not bow to the
machine he used his own brain he said oh
this is what i want to do in my own
household i don't want the government
coming in and having an experimental
drug injected in my children i'd like to
think about it a little bit before we do
that that i think is what your
responsibility would be as a parent i'm
not a parent yet i look forward to
making these decisions one day well i
don't look forward to making these
specific decisions but i suspect that
being a parent has something to do with
using your brain and making the right
decisions related to your children's
welfare your children's health so
mcconaughey obviously calm cool and
collected there that's what he's known
for that's his that's his style
and uh hope we'll see actually what what
the machine
does
what i do think might be happening here
a little bit though is that you do sense
a little bit of a shift right now have
you guys been feeling that like i know a
lot of people right now that are not
vaccinated
that are feeling pretty good about not
being not vaccinated right like they're
just like oh i guess i made the right
decision because it doesn't seem to stop
you from getting coveted it doesn't stop
you from transmitting covet people with
the vaccine seem to be getting sick now
they're on third booster shots and four
booster shots so i know a whole bunch of
good thoughtful people not right wing
conservative crazy maniacs who are kind
of comfortable in their own personal
decision at the moment i also know a lot
of people who suddenly in the last i
would say two three weeks are kind of
like ah maybe i shouldn't have done that
or i don't know exactly what's going on
here
i know a couple people that are having
balancing problems i'm not telling you
you should listen to me when it comes to
your own health but i think there's a
little more to the story at this point
and we all know it right we all know
those conversations are happening in our
own homes in our own networks of course
uh then the me the mainstream media is
offering us uh to that end i interviewed
jordan peterson yesterday part one is up
on youtube right now and the full
episode is up early of course at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh but jordan
was vaccinated now you know he had a
whole slew of of pretty brutal health
problems over the last two years he did
get covered but he did decide to get
vaccinated and i want to share just a
quick 40 second clip of that interview
with you right now you know canadians
who aren't
cannot leave the country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm
look i got vaccinated and people took me
to task for that and i thought all right
i'll get the damn vaccine here's the
deal guys i'll get the vaccine you
[ __ ] leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for covid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
stringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
i mean how much better can we say it
than that so what jordan said at the top
of that first is totally true you no
longer can leave
canada if you are not vaccinated i have
a canadian friend who i
met while i was down in florida last
week who was not vaccinated did not want
to get vaccinated he's in his early 30s
late 20s early 30s perfectly healthy was
making choices for himself and realized
that he was going to be trapped in
canada so he did get vaccinated and then
i saw him in miami jordan further
mentions in the interview that his
father
does not want to be vaccinated his
father i think is probably in his late
80s
does not like being pushed into things
has made a choice not to be vaccinated
jordan backs him up on that choice and
that means his father now is a prisoner
in canada um but to jordan's main point
there where he dropped the f-bomb i mean
how much you know clearer could it be
it's like what was the purpose of all of
this
we we were all told if you just get the
facts you'll get your freedoms back now
frankly my freedoms were not theirs to
to give in the first place there are
there are human freedoms god-given
freedoms god-given rights and the
government's supposed to protect those
things they don't give them to you so
that may have been a flaw in all in many
people's thinking all along that if we
just did what they wanted they would
give something back to us that was not
theirs to give in the first place
but i think jordan's sentiment there and
we clip that and put it on twitter and
it's it's catching fire right now is
quite right they have lied all along
they will continue to lie and what i
will try to do is shine the spotlight on
people like matthew mcconaughey who are
stepping up and i have no doubt that
many of you are stepping up in your own
lives many of you are doing this at work
you're doing it at home you're doing
whatever you can but we need more and
more and more there are more of us we
just don't know it right they don't want
us to see it which is exactly why as i
reference at the top of the show that
youtube starting today will not show you
the dislike counts on videos because
they don't want you to know that we have
wised up to their [ __ ]
so anyway all that said i'm not gonna
focus on a lot of the the covet nonsense
anymore that is my official commitment
to you guys but i will stand up for the
people that are fighting and if you if
you see people fighting please let us
know drop us the the videos at
reubenreport.locals.com we will see them
i will promote people and we will we
will get out of this and whether that
means just we those of us that are
thinking kind of similarly
we will get out of this because we're
just not going to give them the power
anymore and if they want to live in
boxes
with masks and
duct tape around their head then so be
it all right let's talk about racist
jimmy kimmel you know jimmy kimmel of
course is the uh the host of the late
night show over there on abc and he has
done blackface and his former girlfriend
sarah silverman she's done blackface
these people love blackface i don't
really know jimmy kimmel uh it's not a
particularly funny guy he's completely
woke he bows to the to the mob
constantly like he knows that he is a
sinner right he's done blackface so he
knows he's a sinner so he always has to
go in on all of the woke bs that's sort
of the jimmy kimmel thing captured right
there i don't know anyone that's
watching these late night shows do you
guys watch these late night shows have
you ever actually that's kind of
interesting have you guys ever watched
like a late night comedy show
really just like watched a late night
maybe maybe a little bit maybe not
really that's interesting you're 29
you're 29 and hell of you 26 so i got a
29 and 26 years they don't watch these
late night things nobody watches these
late night things anymore like this
ain't johnny carson's tonight show i
remember i think i was a senior in
college i was a senior in high school if
i'm not mistaken 92 maybe i was a junior
in high school i remember the last night
of johnny carson tonight show i stayed
up late stayed up till 11 30 at night i
was such a rebel back then to watch the
last night of the the johnny carson
tonight show anyway nobody cares about
these shows anymore if you're watching
these things and laughing there's
something wrong with you you should have
your head examined maybe that's what the
injections are for but anyway uh kimmel
was talking about kamala last night
she's the vice president that they
installed uh who's gonna take over for
joe when he steps down
which good god we're in a lot of trouble
but anyway uh she was talking about
kamala and basically if you don't like
kamala it's because you're a racist and
a sexist if anything can get the
american people fired up it's
infrastructure so
and biden is alone if americans really
aren't happy with this vice president
kamala harris kamala harris has an
approval rating of 28 which is
makes no sense because she basically has
nothing to do i mean it's like
criticizing a backup quarterback tom
brady's okay i don't love the way blaine
gabbard has his legs folded on the bench
i have to be honest
tommles approval rating uh of 28 even
lower in the 30 percent who approved of
dick cheney in 2008 after he shot a guy
in the face
i think these people are forgetting that
at least 10 percent of the those polled
approved of dick cheney because he shot
a guy in the face
i think i know why kamala's ratings are
low besides sexism and racism which are
the obvious ones
it's because whenever she's next to joe
standing near him behind him she looks
like an assassin she looks like
nebula next to thanos ready to right
especially with the mess
hey kamala this guy's being a wise guy
show them what we do to wise guys
if you laughed at any of that
i don't want you watching this program
anymore okay we're banning you i don't
know how we can do that do we have that
kind of technology yet okay we have
something i got a thumbs up over there
uh you can't watch this program anymore
that's it
now think about there's probably 20
writers on that show they've probably
got to staff about 100 people
20 writers sat there to write that
drivel where he also called most of us
racist and sexist now if her approval
rating is 28 that means her disapproval
rating is about 72 percent that means
he's calling 72 percent of americans
racist and sexist now my disapproval of
kamala harris has absolutely nothing to
do with her sex or her race it happens
to do with the fact that she is at
nothing what do you think kamala harris
really believes nobody really knows
right she's incredibly disingenuous she
comes off as deeply inauthentic i don't
know what she really stands for uh
remember that video
it was about this time last year when
she was pretending that when she grew up
as a kid she celebrated kwanzaa like the
woman is just a deeply
authentic liar she was polling at zero
she was polling at zero percent in the
democratic primary when she dropped out
zero percent within her own pri party
primary and then eventually when the
machine chose biden as the victor they
then chose her as the backup someone
polling at zero percent i mean that's
almost impossible to to poll at zero
percent when there's only about 12
people right uh and the media loved her
from the beginning it may be hard for
some of you to remember this but when
the democratic primary was originally
happening people thought at that first
debate people were like oh she's the
frontrunner and then she left after a
couple weeks again zero percent not one
percent like one percent of the people
like it that's pretty depressing zero
percent of the people like you so so
we're on to something here this dislike
of this woman but then i thought no it
must go deeper it can't just be the
inauthenticness it can't just be that we
don't really know what she stands for it
can't be that she jailed a whole bunch
of people uh when she was attorney
general in california it can't just be
like all that stuff there must be
something else about it and then i
thought wait a minute there is something
else
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh
she should be the joker in the next
batman movie that would make more sense
to being vice president but nobody is
sexist or racist because they don't like
her jimmy kimmel you are a racist you
are in blackface we should have pulled
up that image of him in blackface if you
haven't seen the image of him in
blackface he used to do an impression of
carl malone uh the nba player on the
utah jazz and uh he'd be in full but not
only blackface full body full black body
that's a thing and and he'd be also
making fun of the way carl malone spoke
and whatever so jimmy is just terrible
you're just a terrible human being jimmy
kimmel
and kamala harris
lordy lordy lordy all right let's move
on so the big story at the moment
actually is the kyle rittenhouse trial
now i don't want to get into all of the
specifics of the event that happened now
almost a year and a half ago
but we are going to link to a video that
we did that's a pretty decent recap of
everything that happened related uh to
kyle
the shooting what was going on in
kenosha a little bit of the history it
involved some video from tucker
carlson's show where they did a really
nice
recap of everything that was going on
there but i thought for the purposes of
today because so much of this is
breaking right now i didn't want to get
too much into the history of the story
but i know a lot of you wanted to hear
my opinions on it uh so first i want to
talk really about the way the media has
treated kyle uh more than anything else
because so much of our the disconnect
that we have in society and as i always
talk about that sort of chasm between
what we see with our own eyes online and
what the mainstream media will allow us
to talk about that really is the biggest
issue that we have in society and this
story is a perfect example of it
kyle happens to be a young white kid so
obviously in the mainstream media eyes
no matter what happened even if his life
was being threatened and he was about to
be pummeled by a mob or he was about to
be shot or whatever he's the bad guy in
their view now i don't really care about
narrative i care about truth so if kyle
was out there just murdering people
murdering protesters and shooting people
not in self-defense of course like it's
not even a question it's so stupid to
even have to talk about it of course
then he should be tried and convicted he
should have his right to a fair trial
and everything else
but there were so many people
in the media who over the last year and
a half were immediately condemning him
damning him to hell and basically
condemning not only him but white people
in general and young people and
everything else so tucker cross and did
a really nice recap of some of the stuff
that the media has done related to all
of this last night take a look
but you know never know any of this from
watching the coverage of the trial
nbc news for example just ran this
thoroughly dishonest headline quote
shooting victim at written house trial
said he thought he was going to die
what the article didn't mention it seems
kind of relevant
the shooting victim was pointed a loaded
gun at the boy who shot him
so they're liars you knew that in this
case they have to lie if they didn't
they'd be forced to admit that they were
wrong from the very beginning in case
you've forgotten this is what they were
telling you all last year about kyle
rittenhouse
ridden house is basically what you would
have had in a school shooter he's a 17
year old kid he shouldn't have had a gun
he crossed state lines to supposedly
protect property no he was going out to
shoot people you see the 17 year old who
was radicalized by trumpism took his
ar-15 to kenosha and became a killer a
17-year-old kid from out of state a boy
from out of state drives up to the state
with an ar-15 around his neck
shoots and kills a couple of people uh
shooting wildly running around uh acting
like uh rent-a-cop and it's not good
that a 17-year-old vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people
yeah he drove to a different state to
shoot people that's what happened really
open up your brain let's pour some more
lies in it
actually in point of fact kyle
rittenhouse went to kenosha to clean up
the filth left by the rioting biden
voters the child molester included turns
out the morning of the shooting kyle
rittenhouse was videotaped cleaning
anarchist graffiti off the walls of a
local high school that seems like good
citizenship actually
naturally elected democrats denounced
him as a racist ayanna presley described
rittenhouse as a quote white supremacist
domestic terrorist echoing the msnbc
morning show elon omar did the same
joe biden on the basis of no evidence
whatsoever called the 17 year old quote
a white supremacist
now for the record
the men written how shot were all white
kind of a funny kind of white supremacy
there it turns out that like so much of
the hyperventilating moral outrage we
suffer through every single day the tale
of kyle rittenhouse is a myth
okay so that's just a great job by
tucker and his team that's why i wanted
to show you that full two minute clip
there uh if you want more on the
specifics of exactly what happened that
day again we have a link to our video
which was from september 2020 if i'm not
mistaken uh so you can see actually like
the full sort of chronology of what
exactly happened and that kyle had a gun
pointed to his face and that this was a
kid who was trying not to instigate he
was trying to de-escalate but watch that
and make a decision for that on your own
i should mention also that robert barnes
who is my friend and who has been on the
show this show several times he's one of
kyle's lawyers so we'll get him back on
hopefully in the next couple weeks to
discuss and now i want to show you two
videos from the trial today because this
is all unfolding in the last little bit
um the first one's actually sort of hard
to watch so this is kyle
on the stand himself defending himself
not something that he has to do this is
something that the defense decided that
they would do
uh and he broke down while he was giving
testimony look over my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
there were
three
people right there
that
whatever
right
anyway
you can just relax for a minute sir uh
we're gonna take a break about uh 10
minutes and please don't talk about the
case during the break what read watch or
listen to any economy
okay so that's obviously you know kind
of hard to watch i just want to back up
for a second and talk a little bit about
those cnn and msnbc
commentators contributors blowhards
liars blow beaters whatever you want to
call them who are calling that kid a
white supremacist and joe biden who
called him a white supremacist there's
no evidence literally no evidence that
he's a white supremacist there is no
social media posts anywhere that he's a
white supremacist or anything like that
this is what they do with everything
that first guy in that compilation we
showed you who said that he's a 17 year
old white kid like the perfect you know
mass shooter it's like they're they're
imagining a reality instead of looking
at the reality that's right in front of
them these people are actually dangerous
the amount of people that they are they
are instigating to hate people for no
reason other than the color of their
skin while they call the rest of us
racist anyway if you if you watch the
full video you see that he was clearly
trying to defend himself this was not
someone who was out there to try to hurt
himself now maybe he should not have
been out there maybe too many people are
getting involved in all sorts of things
right now and and we've watched cities
burn and everything's kind of screwy um
but this this kid is not a cold-blooded
murderer uh he was defending himself
look watch the video yourself again it's
in the link down below and if you think
that if he had done nothing he would be
alive you're probably wrong he was most
likely about to be killed or pummeled or
whatever it might be
the trial went on and a few minutes
later this is actually like completely
extraordinary and i think in some ways
might end the trial right here in and of
itself
the judge had to scold the prosecutor
because
kyle wanted his right to remain silent
at one point which of course you have
right like that's one of the things that
we still got while they try to burn
everything down and the judge was not
having any of it
you need to account for this
your honor
i don't want to
i want a jury here
he's commenting on my client's right to
remain silent
i know your honor i am making the point
that
after hearing everything in the case now
he's
tailoring his story
to what has already been introduced
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation for you to talk
about the defendants
silence
and that is and and you're right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but uh it better stop i
understand
this is
i can't think of the case the initial
case on it but it's uh this is not
permitted
i mean that's a really remarkable moment
the the judge saying you're right on the
borderline like that this thing is close
to a mistrial basically you have the
right to remain silent you don't have to
incriminate yourself we all know this
like this is basic 101 watch an episode
of boston legal or l.a law
like we all know this stuff it's just
crazy anyway we will see what happens my
sense is that the prosecution has done a
really poor job i think the defense has
done a decent job um of course you know
what we're seeing from the temperament
online is that you know he's white and
he's young so he's going to get off if
this was a blackhead we'd get him it's
like that's not really a position
what a position would be is oh evidence
evidence leads to something right like
that would be an honest position not oh
i need something to fit my narrative
i think you guys get it um all right
guys oh i'll throw in one comment uh
related to the story earlier bionic
bacon over on reubenreport.locals.com
i'm trans-vaccinated i identify as a
vaccinated person when it suits me
pretty good we should all be
trans-vaccinated more than meets the eye
as optimus prime would say all right
guys part one of my interview with
jordan peterson including that clip we
showed you is up on youtube right now
the full thing it's a little over an
hour is up at rubinreport.locals.com
[Music]
uh we have regular shows for the rest of
the week and then i am off to nashville
i'll be doing candace owen's daily wire
show and i'll be sitting down with her
for our show in her studio which should
be fun and i'll be uh eating some fried
bacon over there in nashville maybe i'll
get some boots this time i couldn't get
boots last night because i have la style
jeans did not realize that you need boot
fit jeans to get to that that's what the
boots were the boot bit fits around the
boot so i walked into a place to get a
boot boot cut they call boot cut not
boot fit okay boot cut that's fine
but i go into the boot place i was like
i'm gonna get some boots and they were
looking at me like that that is not
gonna fit does not fit anyway uh all
right guys i think i think we did it we
didn't we didn't uh bang everyone over
the head with coved i think you're going
to be all right guys so get out there
have fun enjoy your lives and we'll see
you tomorrow